Runk
hello
hello uh we're rolling we're rolling
we're rolling rolling rolling rolling oh
keep rolling rolling rolling rolling
ohing okay cool I think that
that's careful such a nervous passenger
oh we're speeding okay cool um dude I I
don't I'm going to laugh a lot I can
feel it I can feel the laughter the
worst psychic I can absolutely feel the
laugh the worst fortune teller also
life's unraveling remember that dude we
haven't done life's unraveling for a
while already sweared twice and it's
been 30 seconds you always do the swear
meter on me I'm just saying I did it
once and then you did it so it wasn't
just you I did it once I did the f word
and then you the sh why are you counting
I'll stop now because now I'm aware yeah
I don't know because we we normally
don't and it's out of the ordinary to do
two under third in under 30 seconds okay
but anyway what were you just saying
about oh life's unraveling yeah wow that
one that's a good I guess we haven't
done that in a bit huh have you ever
done it on
congratulations probably you've done so
many episodes you don't know anything
I'm sure I have he says
no the biggest fan there is in the world
he's seen every episode more than um
yeah life's unraveling is uh meaning
like when somebody says something like
they're trying to convince themselves
that I feel great I love my new job out
of the blue when people say that out of
the blue life's unraveling the best
thing ever happened to me when they get
fired oh that's the most life's
unraveling under any
circumstance if you say that's the best
thing that ever happened to me your
life's unraveling yeah of course yeah
also what's with those super squat
Arrowhead I didn't put them there uh
Chris did but when you hold them it make
you feel like a
giant anyway dude I will be in wait no
that Phoenix was already right yeah
because it's phix uh El Paso Texas
Albuquerque colog BC Vancouver I'm
coming um Rochester kitner Ontario Shar
Port lisan Houston Texas corpor Christie
go to Chris lea.com i g to do my
birthday show in Durham or is that was
that Durham yeah North Carolina um
interesting City lineup you got there
cool places there all over the place
yeah all over the place it's going to be
all over the place too I'm announcing
more coming up and it's going to be all
over the place nice I like Durham you
ever been to Durham yeah I've been a dur
oh okay man relax I didn't know you Mr
Durham over here Krist is from there oh
really yeah I mean all right man dude
why don't you chill hey take a take a
step back take a seat I'll handle it
from here all right what about the
patreon patreon.com lifeline luxury if
you're not signed up for that you hate
me and our entire family and you want us
to all burn painfully in Hell For
Eternity if you do sign up for it you
love us so we love you back oh wow okay
patreon.com Lifeline luxury and you can
go watch my special grow or die at uh
christ.com you should watch that you
like laughing you like you like life you
like laughing you should watch that like
life dude the worst pitch you like life
I got something for you if you really
like life the private record is coming
out Wednesday January 24th buckle up get
ready hold on to your butts right no uh
it's coming out first episode's dropping
never hold on to your butts be excited
I'm excited the whole world is excited
join the party submit yourself as a
potential guest at theprivate record.com
and make sure you subscribe on YouTube
why do why do why does it do that why do
people do that when when they're going
through a list of things like what have
you ever noticed that they talk like
that when you going to go at when you're
talking about totally why is that
because that's like I do first of all
anytime anyone's on it's not a script
we're not on a script but anytime that
anybody auto pilot exactly on autopilot
with the same words they usually say
they like R rattle it off with a certain
Cadence what is that though it's always
the same everyone does it always the
same that's probably derived somehow
from oldtime radio right right right
right probably wow we got to change it
up dude how but think about it how merch
go to lifeline.com Lifeline merch.com
just change it up dude go to the private
record.com one one with Matt at mata.com
why but now we're doing it like that and
even that's a thing see what I'm saying
you can't I want to make it my own you
know okay go watch my special at ai ai
just a
program.com um actually what we're just
doing is what mattress commercials do
now oh man we used to watch infomercials
together do you ever think about when we
were young and how not how you wish it
was like that again because I don't wish
I was young again that young again I'm
still young I'm the youngest man in Los
Angeles quite frankly um but uh do we
used to watch infomercial so late into
the night I would want to go to sleep
and you would be like no no no no no no
come come on come on just watch this one
and it would be like somebody selling a
long pole that at the end has like a
grabber you know and like you like it's
good for reaching things that are high
up you know and it's just like call the
next however long and you get two more
free yeah or like a a steamer or like
totally a dicer dude a dice everything
that dices well or the the number one
thing though was U how something could
help you make money yeah remember that
guy in the Ridler money coat yeah God
guy I hated that guy yeah yeah yeah what
who was that guy the r money guy you
know who we're talking about right Chris
how could you just be the
Riddler like he was just like had qu it
be instead of question marks it was
dollar bills that was the only
difference though okay oh so it was okay
got it the money Riddler look that guy
up dude let's see if we could find him
he's dead you know he died of HIV wow
you know he died so fast full-blown AIDS
man like had such bad reaction his whole
head fell off man well don't oh he's
still he's still kicking looks like his
gray hair his head fell off from AIDS
you know not a
thing oh no he mixed it up he didn't he
stopped doing wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait I was wrong he did just do
question marks yeah okay he was just the
Riddler right okay right I thought so I
don't like that I don't like that that's
what I was saying it's like why I
remembered it wrong though obviously it
would be like if a guy just was dressed
up his Too Faced and he was like Hey buy
my vacuum cleaner you're like what the
he's just ripping off Batman bad guys
let me tell you something right now no
one in history uhhuh had if he's really
dead had worse breath than than this guy
look at the way he's opening his mouth
you can tell yeah you're right you know
what I'm saying you're right just had
the worst breath halosis though he
brushed his teeth all the time it didn't
matter he wasn't like being rude or or
disgusting he just had it look at that
look at that guy people run from his
mouth yeah yeah yeah I mean dude the
suits he has why is that his thing uh
home alone oh he was that M Park alone
right there um Riddler alone dude uh
yeah I don't know I I you bad breath is
something I don't even
honestly it's something I don't even
like to talk about you say it a lot
though as a joke about people or is that
me no but I'm making it up that it's not
real I'm I do what you do like breath
yeah when you think about someone with
bad bre you tell me I I I yeah there was
this guy I was in an elevator he said
something he had bad breath would like
affect me I would I would say it affects
me to my core well let me affect you to
your core right now I once went on a
date with a girl who was genuinely a
great person I knew her for a long time
before we went on a date we had a nice
little innocent kiss at the end of the
date I have never tasted rat poison but
all I thought was there's rat poison
inside this person because it it it it
just completely consumed me it was like
I I like almost gagged onto her face
Jesus it was so bad did you just like
this oh you have rat poison in your
mouth I didn't know what to do I was so
I was like frozen I was like a deer in
headlights put yourself in that
situation that's
so hor of course I've been around I wish
it was someone I didn't know really
though because it was that made it way
worse you know what I'm saying like I
already knew her and thought she was a
great person oh I wish I wish you were
someone I didn't know yeah that's
exactly um yeah I I I was talking to
somebody the other day I know them
and they were we were talking and they
got close you know and I like the person
a lot so well you're saying it like it
is someone died in the story you know
you're so solemn and I was like you know
talking to the person and they got close
and I liked the person I was like you
know what let them get
close I'm not not going to back up it
was a guy why is it getting so close it
was just one of you know some of those
guys like that they back up like getting
me back up like okay okay it's weird and
a lot of times I go like
this you're good there but if you know
the person no if you don't know the
person what if you know the person you
just let him get in if I know the person
I if I know the person be like bro why
you getting so close that's what I do
yeah yeah yeah but I didn't so I was
like you know what let me ride this out
let me take it for a test drive let me
take this experence for a test drive
paid the price you paid a heavy price
and it hit me and it was like oh h no
okay God that sucks I wish I didn't know
that about it you can tell though when
it's because of some random thing they
happened to it wasn't the worst kind
right okay yeah that's good if it's
because of something they ate I'm kind
of okay with it me too dude actually
100% yeah if it's that guttural rat
poison yeah you know if it's if it's
also if it's there's two types of bad
kind if I can tell they like just kind
of haven't eaten It's Kind it's it's
terrible but it's not as bad as oh this
person just when it gets bad it gets bad
oh wow I actually got a thing see yeah
okay we're done let's start the show
start Theiss hits him to the core hits
him to his core had a burger last night
and I've had a really embarrassing
question to ask
um so I've been talking to this guy for
about a month M um and things have been
progressing very nicely he's a really
nice guy treats me better
than a lot most anyone I've ever been
with and I'm very much like swept up in
my feelings oh um the other night we
went out it was like the fourth date
okay and I just felt like treated like a
princess it was amazing something bad's
coming and uh he walked me to my
door and gave me aug H and kiss goodbye
and I just without um thinking oh the
words I love you came out of my mouth
and I was mortified absolutely mortified
I don't know where it came from I didn't
plan to say that it was literally a slip
of the tongue I it's never happened to
me before that's hilarious and I
backpedal
and he was like what did you say very
nice about it super sweet wouldn't
expect anything else um and anyway um
what would you do in this situation she
just felt so comfortable dude yeah
exactly yeah it slipped I mean the truth
is it's probably I mean only you would
know if I'm wrong about this but like it
probably slipped because what you said
she's so comfortable she didn't it
wasn't like an examined thought where
she was like I love this guy I don't
want to tell him yet maybe I should tell
him maybe I shouldn't but like she was
probably so in the moment
and has some kind of history of being in
moments like that and it's just like she
just came out of she even said herself
it just slipped I think that that is the
thing to say I don't think you I don't
you're obviously mortified she even
blushed when she was telling the story
to her phone camera but um you don't
actually need to be that embarrassed
about it because it actually is
understandable I agree people have brain
slips like that that it doesn't actually
mean you love the person right so I
would imagine you laughed about it in a
moment and then when you got inside you
were obviously mortified but or next
date just in the middle of the date just
casually say like and I'm related to
Hitler and then be like wait a minute no
I'm not sorry you know what I just say
stuff sometimes and my brain does that
and I have no idea none of it is true it
could be different than I'm related to
Hitler it doesn't have to be something
it doesn't have to be something horrible
like I you know melini is my cousin or
whatever doesn't have to be a dictator
thing why does it have to be a dictator
no I'm just it doesn't but uh Omar kadf
Omar Gaddafi or whatever the that guy's
name is yeah Gaddafi he he he's my
husband oh no he's not I don't have a
husband what am I talking about I don't
love you only only can do slips if it's
about a horrible dictator of from
history um actually that would work if
it was like I love pizza wait I'm sorry
but then it's like then it's like then
he'll think you have a kind of problem
yeah true true just be like I don't know
what happened you know what you should
do you should say you just swept me out
of the moment like give him a
compliment and and at the same time take
back that I love you right I just felt
so comfortable I said I don't know why
you made me so comfortable it was such a
pleasant moment that it just like some
kind of like trigger in my
brain I don't know what happened I don't
know what happened Stalin is my best
friend I you know I I I just felt so
comfortable it was such a sweet is my
best friend it was such a sweet great
moment it just slipped in my mouth and
lennin is my
idol John Lenin John Lennon never mind
um yeah that's that's wild that's funny
did you know that that's what she was
going to say when you said oh no you
said oh no before she said it well I
thought actually you know what I thought
what it was it was uh she was GNA say
she farted oh because I know a dude that
that did that on a first date that he
said it went so well come on he said it
went so well they're walking back to her
car cuz they met somewhere uh first time
they ever hung out like as as a
potential couple and he opened the door
for her and she was getting in the car
and he just like without yeah obviously
he didn't even it's the kind of thing
where he didn't even know it was coming
he was comfortable same thing is I love
you thing by the way it actually just
like a lightning strike moment cuz he's
like that doesn't happen to me that's
and that honestly to me that's never
happened I always know something that's
coming I can control it I had the first
fart that came to this past weekend had
the first fart ever that came out and I
had no idea was coming out just this
past weekend yeah I never that never
happened to me before I go oh my god oh
I'm getting older I guess yeah he was
young who the guy that it happened to
man yeah but I just that's crazy that
that lady did that I mean
I feel I feel she was also so sweet I
know it seems like it seems like you're
going to be good I have a prediction you
guys are going to get married and like
have kids and you're going to look back
and be like isn't that the funniest
thing that ever happened and everyone is
even going to be like that is I actually
thought the same thing that I was like
that'd be funniest story when you when
when if when you guys work out yeah I
thought it before you but it's it's cool
I thought it in Dad's balls I thought it
in Grandpa Bam's boss where' you think
it I thought in who whoever Grandpa
Bam's whoever great great grandfather
father ballar I thought oh okay you have
the memory you just don't know whose
balls was cool so anyway
next hey what's up guys I told the
ex-boyfriend of a girl who lives on my
floor that she smells now I never wanted
him to tell her anything but he threw me
under the bus and did just that he went
and told her that I think she stinks um
I only told him because I didn't know if
he ever experienced that with her and I
didn't know how to confront her about it
cuz it's so mean to go out to someone
just be like you stink yeah um so what
do I do I need some advice because now
every time I see this girl in the
hallway it was by the way she smelled so
bad like she hadn't showered in weeks it
would sting up the whole hallway if I
was in the same elevator as her I
literally had to hold my breath that's
why I went to her ex-boyfriend cuz I
needed to do something what um but what
do I do now because she hates my guts
for going to her explo friend about
something like that and I just I don't
know what to do thanks love you I I know
what to say I mean look if it's I would
never recommend this but it is where it
is it's already so far down a certain
path yeah if she's really mean to you
and that's the reason and you and you
explicitly have been told that I think
you actually have license to say I was
like confused I I you're you smell
terrible and we share an elevator and
that's that's like kind of mean to other
people you live around people you live
in a building if you live ater never I
don't but like you live with other
people it's so rude to them to share a
space with people and and subject them
to a terrible body odor well she's not
going to like you after that either but
she what I'm saying is already so far
down the path like you don't need to be
like tiptoeing and apologizing it's like
whatever Al also though you're an idiot
for saying that to
heroy of course you never trust
someone's EX to tell their ex what you
said about them they want to hurt their
ex yeah usually that's a dumb Dum move
dum dum move I I I actually uh was with
uh someone and then later on my friend
started dating her and I um always
thought she smelled kind of
funky and I didn't ask him why would you
I asked our other friend has he ever
eluded oh have you noticed yourself and
what did he say no so I cuz here's the
other thing too you could be like yo if
you want to like I mean not not that
it's backpedaling but like I would I
would do this because I would maybe
think it's true I would be like I have a
really sensitive nose I I just wanted to
know if it was me or not oh that's
that's good because like but it but she
didn't shower for weeks it's obviously
if if if it is that I mean you don't
know you're not it's not like he's
watching her shower or not so he doesn't
know I wonder how he knows the I mean no
I don't know yeah he that's what I'm
point is he probably doesn't know he
probably just saying she didn't shower
for weeks
maybe the ex told him that though that's
such a specific thing to claim he must
have heard that I think that it's just
something he says when somebody SM so
mad and it's fine but I think that's
what it going to talk to me afterwards
about it going to set me down I I uh you
agree with me right on which on which uh
on me saying that uh it was I didn't
know if it was me or not no no that that
he was probably just saying she didn't
show her for weeks and doesn't know that
oh my God so it's all good angry no I I
just gen want to know don't agree with
that no but but you think he has the
he's privy to the knowledge that she
hasn't showered for weeks what I assumed
based on what he said and the way he
said it was was specifically one thing
he had a conversation with the ex he
brought up the smell and the ex said oh
she often doesn't shower for weeks all
right couple so that's okay Matt that's
so much supposing going on that it's
just crazy it is a lot of supposing but
it here's why I suppose it it's such a
specific thing to say with Authority and
conviction which he did he wasn't like
it smelled like she hadn't showered for
a couple weeks he said she really did
and she really hadn't showered for a
couple weeks that is like claiming that
he didn't say so here's the deal he is
either a bonehead idiot Liar Liar not a
liar he learned it Li too specific to
CLA he's bonehead he told the ex that
she smells bad he's a bonehead he's
you're a bonehead dude it's fine look he
seems like a nice guy hon my advice to
you is stop being a bonehead honestly
this kind of guy seems like he'd be in
my circle I like this guy he would 100%
be friends with you and I would be like
that guy such a bonee head dude I be
like I love it yeah but but hold on a
second you you I I get mad at you for
assuming stuff I get mad but he here's
why I'm not assuming he said it so what
I'm you're assuming you're assuming he
made a thing up I'm assuming he knows it
you're doing the assuming I'm not the
assumer you're the assumer it's a bit of
a colloquialism to be like oh yeah he
smelled bad he didn't showerer for weeks
no but it can be but the way he said it
sounded like he had conviction why don't
we listen to it again okay wow why don't
we listen to it again can't believe how
hung up you are on this well it's is it
me that's hung up on it or is it you
that's yes cuz you're keep bringing it
up all right fine I'm I'm fine with that
it's me that's hung up on it I like to
be hung up on it I want to hear it again
okay hey what's up guys uh I told the
exboyfriend of a girl who lives on my
floor that she smells now I never wanted
him to tell her anything but he threw me
under the bus and did just that he went
and told her that I think she stinks um
I only told him because I didn't know if
he ever experienced that with her and I
didn't know how to confront her about it
cuz it's so mean to go out to someone
just be like you stink right um so what
do I do I need some advice because now
every time I see this girl in the
hallway it by the way she smelled so bad
like she hadn't showered in
weeks elevator as her I Lally had to
hold my breath okay okay she said he
actually said specifically like yeah the
pause through me but you're right look
look here's who I am I'm such an enous
I'm such an enormous man you're not
getting out of such a big man it's not a
good thing I have such a big mind and
heart and it is open my mind and my
heart that if I am wrong I am
immediately willing to admit it and
change my view to accommodate the more
correct view I am a great man and this
is evidence Donald Trump Donald
Trump yeah it was so crazy I knew what
was going on the whole time and I you
know I don't want to gloat because you
can gloat cuz it's so rare that you're
right and I'm wrong so go ahead and
gloat take a parade there we go now
that's take a Victory lap have a parade
you were right and it's fine I'm I'm
good with here's why I'm okay with not
being right life's
unraveling because now I have the
correct information and I am right now
because I think the right thing all I
care about is the truth I'm a truth
finder I'm a truth Seeker I'm a truth
lover I embrace the truth whatever the
truth is and all I care about is
possessing that truth enough if you have
the truth I'd love to possess it from
you if Chris has the truth I'd love to
possess it from him if Anthony has the
truth he never does but it say he did in
hypothetical I would try to possess it
from him all right all right all right
I'm a truth possessor okay what's next a
truth possessor so Chris thanks for
everything that you do um so my issue is
my girlfriend of 5 years broke up with
me about 6 months ago and late I've been
having these feelings of dread I I'm
really concerned about her I worry about
her wellbeing I hope that she's okay we
don't have any sort of contact or
anything like that but I just get these
feelings of worry about her interesting
I was wondering if that's normal and is
there anything I can do to stop these
feelings as they arise thank you did he
say he broke up with her or she broke up
she broke up with him well then that is
a little bit weird why she broke up at
you I I he's not here but I would wonder
why where the dread is coming from right
like why are you so worried about
someone who broke up with
you maybe there's some kind of history
there that we don't I guess there's
grief and he's just experiencing it in a
weird way like so yeah it's not weird
but I think honestly and this is this
sucks dude but with breakups sometimes
the only way to get over stuff is
actually time it's literally like a
physical injury the body will heal
eventually your heart so to speak will
heal
eventually um that's five years is a
long time man and and 6 months is not or
five months however long you said is not
that long it's not that long but well I
would say it probably will go away but
also it'll definitely go away the we we
wait the present a little bit too much
and we think in the present things
aren't going to go away and things are
never going to change because we're
feeling those things right now but yeah
check it out check into your vast
experience of Life you've changed so
much everyone has our feelings are
constantly changing our states of mind
constantly changing you will get over
this too it's not that weird what he's
feeling check it out okay and then look
at this what happened it didn't stay
like this it changed right yeah so maybe
you were going to think that it was
going to change like this if it going
say like this it's not you got something
on your knuckle to me well but let me
hook you up don't say yo wait hang on
let me hook you up no it's all good um
uh yeah so anyway stuff changes see
look that is a great display of change
that's what I you have anything to say
to him besides that
that's all you have to say that's the
only thing I have to say is look hey and
that's how I'm going to teach it to
Calvin and Billy I'm a little thrown
though why do you think he feels grief
about someone who broke up with him it
well well it might not dread rather
sorry but it it might not be
about her well now that really you
really feel that way like I really am so
you're saying the only thing oh I hope
she's okay would be if I broke up with
that person and I hope they're okay
without me because I broke up with them
I didn't want to break their heart no in
responding to him I'm trying to wonder
what I he asked if it's if we think it's
weird like I I don't know actually is
that is a little bit weird to have
someone break up the times I've been
broken up with oh wait I've never been
broken up with I'm sorry but I'm
imagining if I had man dude Me No
actually that's that's a joke I have
been broken up with and it sucks and um
I don't remember worrying about her ever
you know what I'm saying like worrying
about her that's not exactly right in my
I don't know I mean I I guess I've been
broken up with and like I'm when I think
about the people that broke up with me
I'm like I hope they're doing well but I
guess it's not I'm worried I'm not
worried exactly yeah yeah I kind of he
said dread dread is such a particular
thing it's terrible I feel dread all the
time never about my ex I feel dread
about the way I was in relationships
past yeah and I feel dread about like
it's more like regret I guess but like I
don't know I don't feel dread about what
is going on presently with any of my AC
you just be like me and feel dread all
the time but anyway well I do actually
just
judge you know Judge Dread yeah I am the
law remember did you see the Remake yeah
with uh the boys Bo Carl Urban no I saw
dread and Judge Dread yeah me too same
cool I've seen every dread movie they've
ever made Judge Dread is actually really
sick um the law dude people really liked
the Remake like critics like Dread isn't
that weird it was kind of cool I thought
was it I thought it was kind of cool
yeah that's like such a movie I'd watch
though I like yeah me too actually I
liked how it was contained yeah me too I
love that I loved that and and and and
that I can be like that if I really
wanted to be like that and there was a
project I could be like that like what
judge I could be like Jud I could be
like Dread Judge Dread in what way save
everyone or whatever he
did I don't remember what he did but I
could do it how do you know you could be
it then I remember watching it and
thinking I could do
it watching dread thinking I could do
that wow all of it's like futuristic
stuff that doesn't even exist you know I
am the law singing uh what I how I would
wrap that up though
is I think nothing in the wake
of uh a long relationship as you're like
grieving I don't think anything's
particularly weird yeah I agree people
are weird they're very particular and
and specific we're all very specific
individuals with specific brains and
they all do different kinds of [__] so
it's not that weird I wouldn't worry
about it but you know things change
you'll get better every time I hear
somebody say the word particular I think
of Taken I have a
particular up cut I have a particular
set of skills and I will use
them you know so
insecure dude that would be great if
that I have a particular set of skills
hello what do you think of that did you
hear did I cut out hello oh you're there
hold on one second let me go to the
living room
so anyway do you have my daughter you
said daughter right um there's a new
movie they're trying to do Aaron eart
version for Bricker yeah the brick layer
dude I saw it was like number eight you
saw the movie no no no no but I will oh
I will oh I'm going to see that quicker
than you can say brick Lair you know
what I'm saying well you haven't seen it
yet and I could have said it like five
times but say brick brick I saw it so
hold on is that oh wait yeah and after I
saw the trailer for The Brick I
immediately watched the trailer for
taken and I was like
nice try well they dude they keep trying
to do that nice try eart they they keep
you know how many actors see what Liam
niss did and they're like all hey agent
all of them where's my big second act as
his name what's his name did it with
silent night Joe kinman well that's not
so much a second act he's still in his
first Act of his career I'm saying yes
yes yes the older actors who can't get
the big leading man roles anymore
probably look at it and like how did he
pull that off that was Oscar Schindler
yeah crazy I mean yeah so many I mean uh
what's his name michs um you know who
did it was the dude from
um [__] what's his name Pat Dylan not
Dylan MC one of those guys tried to do
it tried to do it oh really it just came
out what do you mean one of those D
MC no it's not Dy mcder der
[__] der [__] ended up doing a lot of
Indies which I think is kind of cool not
that guy der [__] the other guy derit
[__] did it did what though like he's
action movies oh he did yeah of it oh
okay I would watch that what's the guy's
name not that one I you said dermit
morrone you spell that yeah I know it's
pretty weird name right there it just
came up yeah just obviously just type in
the little bit type in the way it sounds
well he look at him with gray yeah he's
in he's in whatever look at the latest
one dud you know what he's so funny in
huh he's so funny in that movie with
James Marsen and Jack Black that the dra
train what is that
called he's so funny that wait hold on
bri what is that first one ruthless
break water ruthless obviously oh cool
it has a 4.9 rating and it's the worst
title too like oh that is
basically hey I would watch that yeah I
love the preview I saw the preview it
looks very um like in it it would be on
Cinemax yeah dude I love Jeff
F if I could look like anyone who isn't
me throughout history I would look like
Jeff feah really yeah yeah don't do that
I wouldn't necessarily disagree with
that yeah Jeff F is so sick looking dude
both as an old guy and when he was in
the lawn mow what's this that he's
playing we don't trailer for ruthless oh
Harry's daughter was murdered four years
ago raped her and left her to die in a
ditch what is he trying to
do oh look at him he looks great he
looks great but look obviously C
obviously can't fight right it's it's
there's one thing here where he
obviously he's just
like
nothing H has happened you know nothing
just doors opening and closing we have a
legal obligation to report any
suspicions of abuse take your fights
har it
hones it honestly looks really bad this
looks awful but I would watch it me too
I would like it kid I think you ought of
on business coach before I leave tonight
I'm definitely breaking your right arm
oh that's what I say to a lot of people
have a minute what is it the worst
hoodie yeah he looked bad there he looks
good though he looks good yeah ad my Bo
solve all your problems what's this this
crew is known for traffing girls across
lines taken so
taken where not right here wait yeah
that wait there's one thing it was the
hand
thing you're not a police officer let me
do my job in it you know
yeah I don't care if I spend the rest of
my life in
prison this is a big upgrade from the
sketchy places I've been to been in
business for there's Jeff FY dude I'm
going to kill them
but fake
name they always try to do like the star
is yeah Aaron eart is the brick layer s
is sa [__] later on myON is dude
ruthless how funny would it be to make a
movie where a guy straight up can't
fight but he's still like but it's the
same movie but every time he's just like
and he's like wouldn't go on very long
because he would lose the fight no no no
but he keeps winning oh that would like
the and and they don't explain it and
he's just
like yeah that would be great dude same
music
hey like this running running at the guy
right and the guy just guy just moves
out of the way cuz he's hit he wins you
you're not understanding the P it's
goofball comedy okay I mean relax it
just so happens the most mad you got he
keeps winning on this show is me not
understanding this fake trailer you're
making up in your head right now like
he's on the ground and he just goes like
this and the guy's
like okay and then it's just like
christalia is [__] wants to be in it so
bad that'd be
great they got my daughter
D I'm gonna get him D they're not gonna
know what hit him
D
ding
hey and at every
time and every single time the a fight
is about to start and he does the the
the like the wind up the the bad guy
goes oh no see that's Comedy Zone though
no but it's not though it's done like
it's not comedy dude dude you're getting
so pipe and hot right now all right it's
really good cinematography and the music
is not comedy we're getting into life
luxury Zone let's continue with the
submissions I like that I like your
movie idea though okay okay think it's
great a condom on his hey what's up uh
Chris toer and Matthew so inse secure
robot a hammerhead sh this guy you guys
know when you're like he's a hammerhead
yeah out there right and you're like
doing what you're doing has said
anything yet yep and you turn around and
you're like whoa so high
uh anyways love the show guys wor
submission dude worst submission he's a
hammerhead he is a condom since he's
trolling us why are his eyes on the side
of his head he is a flounder this is
that you know what that is he's Stewie
Griffin all grown up what happens is
when he turns his head you can't see it
anymore cuz it's completely flat like a
pancake you know what I'm saying yes yes
yes yes that's unbelievable why did
Salvador Dolly paint this guy's face
yeah that's a good question this is why
Honestly though is an unrolled condom on
the tip of his head no dude that is an
unrolled condom on the tip of his head
dude look at it I know it looks like the
tip of a [__]
mhm covered by and the four that's what
the hoodie is the four skins down right
exactly and also everything in that
visual is gray there isn't one thing
that's not gray besides even his skin
besides his pink face his
teeth okay anyway you could tell that
guy's a bad
kisser wow wow I I know it for as as and
this I know be true what is that thing
and I know this to be true yeah I know
that this I know to be true this I know
to be true I know this much is true
that's the Wally Lamb book that's the
book and that's what I meant to do
really yep and I know to quote the title
of a Wally Lamb book and I know this
much is true yes you don't know who
Wally Lamb is yes I do he wrote that
book with the [__] fetus on the
cover okay all right let's do another
one Jeff F Millennial pause hey guys big
fan um I'll cut to it I have a father
that's in the hospital unexpectedly for
35 days oh no the holidays are stressful
the timing stressful I can't stop
thinking about the way way you guys have
described how you pee through your jeans
rather than just use the fly you like
fet the top open oh rather than pull
them down to your knees I've been
thinking about this nonstop for several
weeks now
serious you know I have a size 12 shoe
your boy's beefy like I'm I'm with you
guys and I just use the fly pop it out
do my business put it back in no harm no
foul I don't have time to filet the top
it's justra dud um please help me
understand what the hell you guys are
doing I I I'm lost I need your help
here's here hey my dad's dying I pee
crazy here's the deal using your
fly to pee is such risky business that
you're just like Flirting With Disaster
take the extra Split Second to also undo
the button and pull all of it down so
it's all out and about in the air not
risk anything you're saying it's it's
you're saying it's take the extra second
dude I would argue it takes longer to
just take your penis out of the fly
because you got to finagle yeah the
finagling is way quicker to just go boom
and open it all than it is to go and try
to and the finagling is nil when you
pull it all down the finagling is
maximum amount when you open your fly
got to make sure nothing hits the metal
you know cuz it's so big in my case you
got to get it through the zipper and
make sure also you don't want it to
touch because it's cold the zipper gets
cold too like why are we risking what
why are why are we participating in this
risky business if we don't have to so
forign um yeah it's you're you're you're
wrong you've been living a lie honestly
you've been living it wrong it's so much
easier to do it the other way and I'm
sorry about much and I'm sorry about
your dad the dad thing like what's going
on like don't don't start with that cuz
now I'm sad I know I'm sad think about
the guy's de two sad things you know his
dad and then also he doesn't know how to
take his PE the unfortunate way he does
he pees it's just terrible okay well
hopefully your father recovers and
hopefully you learn hopefully you your
father recover yeah hopefully he's not
the guy that taught you that honestly um
Mom read the Wally Lamb book and so I
know that's what I know about it so Mom
read mom read it a long time ago and I
remember this much I know to be true yes
no I know this much is true I know this
much is true and I remember seeing that
I remember thinking about how stupid it
is to say I know this much is true when
you can just call the book true I mean
that is not the same meaning that's true
I know I know this is true would be a
better way to say but this that's he's
saying it how he wants to say it dud
also Wally Lamb that book is like it
sucks but it's crazy successful have you
have you read it I've read it why did
you read it because it was there one day
what's it about it's a I mean you don't
want to know it's about a guy who they
actually made a miniseries out of it
didn't they Mark Ruffalo I think was in
it of course he was you know yeah
recently though too like way after the
book they were like well it's boring
should we get Mark Ruffalo he got a guy
whose like twin brother died or
something right and when they were
little and now he's divorced it's just
like about a guy who's struggling in
life oh man
yeah okay
next Alec Baldwin Matt Chris love the
show got uh need some advices uh so my
mother is 75 years old such a cool and
she's on Facebook unfortunately
she falls for all the things right um
I'm talking about this the things that
say copy and paste this to your status
if you want to keep Facebook free
because Mark Zuckerberg's going to start
charging next
week recently she shared a post that
said uh sadly most people will keep
scrolling but like and share if you
support our Vietnam vets and it's uh the
picture is the cast from Tropic Thunder
no uh just looking for some advice what
should I do just let these things go um
should I address them one by one should
I tell her that she needs to run all of
her post through me
first uh yeah it be fun thanks I mean I
that's the last one would be funny it's
fun for you exactly but I I think here's
the thing and I've thought about this
too I don't
think I don't think people past a
certain
age can understand so media it's not
that they don't it's not that it's hard
for them to I think that they cannot I
think that it came too late in their
lives that they cannot understand it so
trying to explain to her won't work I I
just promise you it won't work now
here's the thing that might work you you
tell her there are scammers on there
that can really mess up your life and
because you don't know I would like you
to run posts by me if you think think
that would be okay or interesting or
funny or whatever but like she's never
going to like learn in the classic sense
of the word she's just not going to
learn how to do it she cannot she cannot
do that I think about this cuz like
every generation goes like right like of
course you know if you pick up the phone
and somebody's like hey I need your
social security number not to do that
but like if you're 80 and you're like oh
did I order this thing okay may be you
know right like now they have things
where they call you and they say can you
hear me and you say yeah and then they
use that for consent on something else
really wait why they record it and then
use it as your voice to say yes to
something else and then take your money
oh God but that's what I'm saying like
it's constantly changing so and then and
just look at AI like the scams are going
to get so crazy well that's what I'm
saying like you there will be video that
you will be indistinguishable you can
still kind of tell but like there will
be video that's indistinguishable and
you won't be able to tell and and I
won't and and people are age will be
like so it will be so hard for them to
understand it uhhuh yeah totally and but
here's the thing it's going to get to so
good that it's going to be hard for
anybody that right well yeah I read a
story about a mother who got a call from
her daughter's phone she rather she saw
on her phone her daughter was calling
she picks up her daughter is on the
other line The Voice she knows to be her
daughters right begging for help begging
for money to be sent immediately to this
thing for whatever reason it was all
yeah all AI produced it's really [__]
up stuff from that woman's daughter like
how are we going to ever get past that I
don't know we're not going to be able to
no I know you know we're going to have
to be like what is our code word right
and it can't just be like birds it's
going to have to be like birds fly south
to the like you're going to have to have
a whole poem worth of of words to verify
it it's someone you
know that's the only way around
it so my advice to you is have a poem
for that you and your mom write a poem
quick and give it to your mom have a
memorize it yeah it's it's odd it's it's
uh it's really odd but you're right dude
you're gonna have to have words like
that have yeah have her run by you see
if that's not too annoying for you right
get her on board that that way though
you have to scare her scare her into
thinking she's going to get scammed give
her good examples they're easy to find
tell her these are ways people get
scammed they don't know they're getting
scammed it's very common old people to
get scammed right now uh so just yeah
but you know also that's kind of funny
all the things you described and let's
face it everyone who's 75 is doing that
too yeah but if she's doing that stuff
you worry about that's what I meanu
fishing and all that stuff totally
totally just make sure she never gives
anyone any information log in or
otherwise she can post about Tropic
Thunder Vietnam Vets all she wants It's
just tough It's just tough because like
yeah I don't know get off Facebook don't
on Facebook yeah but that's her social
life now I know I know I know yeah are
you on Facebook no I haven't been on I
have an account I haven't been on for I
was just talking about this I haven't
been on Facebook for like at least N9
years wow yeah do you no I don't have it
I mean I have a fan page but I I don't
you have a guy that runs it I mean I
have fans too so it's all good so don't
don't think you're da while all
right
Ohr a b about to get reconstructed knee
surgery second time and my question is
afterwards I'm always a super big
emotional wck all the meds they put me
on so how do I deal with that let me
know I mean you're calling a little late
you're literally about to go under the
knife you know we're not going to turn
around the advice in two hours yeah I
also we talked to that guy in Golden
hour before and here actually I don't
recognize him are you sure yeah I think
yes we have talked about him we talked
to him here his name is Joel and we were
making fun of his oh that's that guy
yeah he looks handsome he is handsome he
was handsome he didn't look as handsome
in the other video yeah we talked about
it we talked about how he was handsome
gotcha got me in that one so anyway um
did you do that because I always say got
out of that one Gana kick Mass yes I did
yeah there we go so I'm good at being
putting the pieces together nice
actually no one's worse at putting the
pieces together than
me it's true um it's true you are a
[__] idiot completely agree anyway
uh dude one
time man my exwife Emily oh God yeah
dude she got her wisdom teeth out and I
had to uh you know obviously pick her up
and take her back and bro oh I I vaguely
remember this she was so funny the nurse
was like so here's what we're going to
do she she was behind her the whole time
going like
this tears just like
this what like cry laughing or yeah like
she was talking she was mouth full of
gauze the nurse was like behind her she
was this she actually goes like
this oh my god wow that's that's like a
Christen wig character oh dude it was it
was so funny dude yeah and then one time
you were yeah I was just going to bring
what was the thing that you was with you
you say you're a race car driver right
you brought me to get my wisdom teeth
out and I kept talking about how I had
to get to the racetrack because I Was a
Race Car Driver and I needed to get I
had a race right then that all this
stuff was making me late for that I
would like to me I was like I can't I I
remember being like yeah okay all right
so you got to get the race track okay
like I was just like I guess go with it
you know why why why just why argue
imagine if I got arguing with you like
no you're not you're not a race car
driver M yeah uh we get no fight no but
I took you to your reconstructed knee
surgery you did oh remember that when
you had your meniscus repaired yeah you
weren't that like loopy dude I didn't
feel loopy at all after that one yeah I
I I I got out and maybe for like a split
second I remember cuz here's what I
remember thinking I remember I got out
there were remember they were Wheeling
me out and I go ah [__] ah feels is that
it [__] I said swear words and then the
nurse was like you're lucky the other
nurses here she doesn't allow the swear
words and I remember getting mad being
like don't say that the first thing I
come out I I'm on drugs like I said [__]
oh you must have not been too Under the
Influence then because that is exactly
what you would think if exactly that's
my whole point about this is that I
wasn't Under the Influence so um but
this last time when I did went nose you
know what happened yes I fought about it
on here yeah and they were trying to pin
me down and I was Wolverine coming out
of the [__] why were you doing that
like what was do you remember was going
through your head oh no I I was blacked
out I don't I don't have any memory of
it I mean I remember a couple things
they told me it happened and I said you
didn't even remember and then no no I I
did not know it happened okay straight
up yeah that's scary it is scary I
remember I went under I think I've said
this before on the show but I went under
for my sinus surgery and it took too
long and the drugs kicked in before I
went under and it was the best feeling
I've ever had in my entire life it took
too long what do you mean never usually
when they they say countown from 100 and
you get to 99 and a half and you're just
right right right it took like two or
three minutes and I could feel the pain
drugs and it felt so good really yeah
see that scares me it's terrible I never
felt terrible terrible memory amazing
experience because I remember it and
it's the best I'll ever feel in my life
oh [__] me up dude all right well let's
move on then that [__] me up yeah it
[__] up a lot of people hey what's upos
um my name is Dan actor based in
Vancouver um I wanted to call in and get
your guys
opinion how to regain your motivation
after having a really shitty audition or
call back um I was in the casting room
for the first time about 3 weeks ago and
uh everything that could have went wrong
I feel kind of went wrong oh no um my
mouth went dry I couldn't take Direction
well like I the more Direction they gave
me the more that I thought I was like
[__] it up so I was very very much in
my head and I was more focused on trying
to pronounce the words correctly cuz my
mouth was so dry than I was on the
actual scene um I know it's so stupid to
to to audition and do commercial
auditions and I feel like I'm just like
losing motivation for doing it but I
also don't want to be the guy who just
quits after one bad experience so I
would love to get you guys' opinion on
on kind of how to keep going and work on
my own kind of creative Outlets to keep
myself busy while I'm waiting for
auditions I love you guys I love the
podcast you guys both seem so cool and
been been a big fan of both you for a
while so hopefully this makes on the
show but I'm at 1 minute and 1113
seconds now so I don't know not bad we
we'll find out I was in I'll be in
Vancouver soon bro Chris you're on Dan
Dan you're on the show and Chris will be
in Vancouver soon so you should buy a
ticket go Chris's show uh uh but yeah
that
that first of all it's not stupid to
audition for no all what you mean is the
process of doing it you feel stupid but
also the process is ridiculous that's
Universal but doing it is not it's just
the game it's a mean yeah exactly means
to an end it's the only way it could
possibly work um but you the best advice
I've heard and this is actually from an
acting coach not to me but I heard her
give it to a group and it was
to
visualize or think of or yeah even
visualize a not just bad auditions but
every audition as a piece of toilet
paper or a bunch of toilet paper right
and the audition itself
as a dump you
took at the end no matter how horrible
the dump was painful whatever smooth
easy easy breezy short
long it's over all the all no matter
what and you flush the toilet paper no
matter what it could be an easy breezy
good one you don't keep the toilet paper
as a souvenir and if it's a terrible one
you don't remember it for a long time
you flush it down all the same you FL
good good audition bad audition whatever
audition you flush it down it has to go
away because you need to get used to it
and it's literally just one part of the
process I mean she kind of was a life
coach she was an acting coach oh she
said that no this was somebody said this
yes yeah I thought you were saying it no
that's I'm I'm quoting an acting
remember what Dad would always say leave
it in the
room or was that probably for me because
I was doing auditions and [__] I guess
yeah yeah he would just be like just
leave it in the room don't think about
it yeah it's same idea you you don't
hold on to it but here's the thing don't
hold on to the good ones
either understand them all to be
transitive experiences and they're going
to go away some of them will be terrible
some will be great but they don't matter
after they're done they don't matter
flush it down the toilet no matter what
take a [__] and flush it down the toilet
yeah
that's cool yeah that she said that it
is cool that she said I think about it
all the time about a lot of things my
auditions are shits here's let me let me
tell you why yeah she should have
started it like that yeah auditions are
big fat smelly dumps let me tell you
when I audition I take
shits walk it back with
me um yeah but you have better advice I
mean you've auditioned well audition the
AUD the whole audition process is just
absolutely it's just stupid it's shitty
it's you it's unnecessary dude um it's
so stupid that even on the other side of
the table I feel embarrassed for the
people who have to do it you just don't
I I decided that if I'm ever going to do
stuff again I'm just not going to
audition like I don't care okay but that
doesn't apply to this guy right true
right but that's what I'm telling you
that's how stupid it is like I I I I
wish it could change and I don't know
how it how it changes because it's just
it's so they're so up there own ass with
it this isn't helping but it's just some
directors some really big directors
actually refuse to even hold them they
only accept on tape auditions well
that's how it should be I know I agree
yeah but that's a that's a newer thing
um yeah I I I uh it's just it's not they
a lot of these people think that they're
like Reinventing the wheel or like
changing the world with this movie
that's going to come out on [__] you
know tuby oh yeah your movie is not
going to change the world in fact it's
not going to anything so it's like hire
a guy you
know anyway uh this doesn't help good
though you want it to be good but you
stop suck guessing yourself you know who
could do it here's another thing that I
think really helps actors understand how
much control they have over the process
and therefore how much they should
really feel responsible for it going bad
or well when an actor walks into an
audition walk the moment they walk in
the casting director director producers
whoever already know with to about 90%
degree sometimes they can be surprised
but they already know whether this actor
for this role has a chance to get it or
not because in their minds they have the
way a person looks this should free you
up because here's why if you walk in and
you're and they think you look right for
it you have a huge leg up so just be
yourself and do the thing you were going
to do if you walk in and they you don't
line up with what they have in their
mind you're not going to get it anyway
so have fun and just have the experience
both ways it doesn't matter just have
the experience you're very very what you
do in the room has way less impact than
you think it does you're either already
going to get it maybe or already never
going to get it for sure when the moment
you walk in before you do a single bit
of acting and that's just the harsh
reality people have it in their heads
the way a ro someone's supposed to look
for a role and there's no getting it out
of their hands yeah so let that free you
up also auditions are shits all right
should we do one more uh do should we or
yeah let's do one more yeah yeah yeah
okay hey Chris and Matt uh Elmo from
Connecticut here the most boring place
on Earth um Chris I've been watching
your [__] since like seventh grade now
I'm 20 so you've aged me thank you uh so
I'm in the military now and I'm in the
Infantry so in the small minute periods
of time that we do have free to
ourselves I was just wondering if you
guys have any advice on the best way to
maximize my learning when it comes to
like financial [__] or just like cuz I
want to use these like next few years on
my contract to like when I get out I'm
like set like I [__] I know what I'm
doing I'm I'm I'm a civilian and I'm
[__] I'm like investing and like I
got my finan is straight and I like can
just like I know what I'm doing cuz
before I joined I'm I'm kind of a
dumbass no one ever taught me how to do
anything so I'm trying to kind of go
through life alone right now so yeah uh
just the best ways to maximize my times
like any good books for just learning
basic adult [__] like I'm talking
finances and things of that nature but
um yeah that's pretty much it thank you
love you guys peace out oh dude hey you
know what I don't know oh well I do
first of all that hoodie right into the
show and tell us what that is that is a
[__] rat hoodie enjoy it says enjoy
are you sure okay I think it's a great
hoodie I don't want think so okay so
send me a link or send the show a link
and it'll get to me um I'll buy it first
that being said wow you know um I think
that that's tricky BEC it's hard to look
at time like I got to maximize it I got
to maximize it because then it's like
you feel all this
pressure but I think the right the best
way to do it is obviously not my brother
my brother is someone you admire and
he's an example rather of someone you
admire that has no possible advice to
give you in this Arena because he's
never read a book in his life but there
there are people there are people who
you admire who actually probably have
given either an interview or have
written some kind of article or there's
something written about them where they
talk about the things that have inspired
them or the things that they look to
whether it be Finance or philosophy and
life or
whatever just keep looking to the people
you admire role models and I don't mean
like you look up to them and want to be
like them but I mean people like that
you look out in the world and think
they're doing their thing and I admire
how much passion they have for it and
how good they are at it and how much
they love what they do or whatever it is
pinpoint those people whether they do
the thing you want to do or not and and
and just model yourself after them the
way they describe themselves the way
that they say they go about things
because honestly you can
find too many books on the subject of
how to invest your money how to maximize
your time there's just too much written
on that [__] you need to look to the
people you already admire and see how
they do that thing and I know that's you
doing this right now but
unfortunately he's never read a book in
his life that's not true I've read the
client and I I I've read other books too
but I read I've read books yeah did you
read Congo I have read Congo what do you
think about Congo I asked you because I
knew you I only when I think of the
Congo when I think of Congo I only
remember the movie with and I only
remember the same ER gics over and over
again Tim Curry yeah yeah why do you
think that's so funny dude because it's
so stupid it's another one of those
things that you guys like for some
reason have stuck in your head yeah the
same idog glyphics Ela and again the
same ID this it's it's hard to say
actually idog glyphics the same idog
glyphics over and didn't we watch it on
this show before yeah I think we did
watch that on luxury I think yeah oh
yeah uh it's a kind of great stuff you
get over on luxury yeah so you can go
over to Lifeline luxury get a uh
patreon.com Lifeline luxury and uh you
get the uh the episodes of that we got a
bunch of them out there right now I
think there's 20 um but anyway you can
go sign up for that that' be great and
I'll also go I'm coming to Vancouver and
El Paso and all sorts of places
chris.com and uh check out Matt's
podcast coming out soon private record
coming out Wednesday baby this Wednesday
January
24th first episode subscribe on YouTube
and leave a comment for us here thank
you
is that it wow what
do
hello
hello hello
will
hello
hello hello